when nvidia's CEO told the world that
the RTX 570 would deliver RTX 490
performance for almost onethird of the
price I said prob I but now that it's
here it's clear that I was wrong I'm
seeing it and yet I don't believe it
this is cyberpunk running at 4k on our
5070 and it is getting more FPS than the
RTX 49 that is right beside it but how
many blades is that fan supposed to have
and does my car have extra bumpers
impossible without artificial
intelligence obviously the RTX 5070 was
never going to match the 490s
capabilities without a little bit of uh
AI doping but come on I was at least
hoping that it would beat the RTX 470
super in raw power and yet in Allan Wake
at 1080p these two cards are dead hide
and at 1440p it wins by a mere 1 FPS is
there anything to be excited about well
yes in spite of his advancing age LeBron
is actually dunking better than ever no
I mean about the RTX 5070 sorry despite
nvidia's advancing profits dunking on
them is better than ever all right then
let's get to it after this layup to our
sponsor threat Locker I went to their
zero trust world event last month where
they had some awesome activities and
even unveiled a few new Advanced
features like web control and Patch
management click our Link in the
description or keep watching to the end
of the video to learn
more since this is currently nvidia's
entry card for the 50 Series why don't
we start with our entry resolution 1080p
with all real frames no dlss upscaling
and no Ray tracing and you know what
while we actually did get identical
performance to last year's 4070 super in
Allen wake 2 we did find improvements in
some other titles black myth Wukong sees
a 5% increase and we even got a sizable
8% Improvement in average FPS in
cyberpunk 2077 and in returnal
unfortunately that's where our Good
Times stop rolling cuz in Red Dead
Redemption 2 The Last of Us Part One and
F1 2024 the 50 70 actually loses to the
super I need a moment to process this
okay I'm good and now it's time to add
insult to injury because not only does
it lose to its last gen counter part but
in F1 it also loses to amd's RX 7800 XT
a GPU that launched a year and a half
ago for
$500 but all right lonus maybe the move
to gddr 7 though is going to help it
pull away from the crowd when we kick
our resolution into mid gear mid gear is
1440p oh boy you guys better be ready
for this because instead of tying in
Allen wake 2 this time the 57d wins by
one frame per second but instead of
losing to Red Dead Redemption 2 it ties
this time as for the rest it looks like
overall at 1440p the 5070 manages about
a 4% improvement over the 4070 super
though this card was never meant to
compete in traditional raster let's talk
more about Ray tracing results let's do
because it turns out when Nvidia uses
amd's Kryptonite and starts tracing Rays
the 5070 pulls away from team red pretty
handily beating even the mighty 7900 XTX
on average across our 1080p test Suite
however it is worth noting that if we
remove black myth Wukong which was a bit
of an outlier it falls back to bouncing
in between the 470 super and 470 TI wait
try to read positively uh okay the good
news is that at
1440p H who am I kidding it's literally
the 4070 super again with only returnal
standing out as a clear win with a
6.5% uplift as for 4K guys we didn't
even bother testing that due to the 570s
anemic 12 GB of vram what what is the
deal with this card then the 570 TI
might not be available at its MSRP which
totally blows but at least that card
performs in theory it's like 30% better
than this thing that is not a TI non-ti
difference so why does the 5070 feel
like a whole lower class of card rather
than a proper 70 well because it pretty
much is we won't dive too deep into
nvidia's new Blackwell architecture
since we've done it a few times already
but we do need to talk about which
Blackwell dies goes into which cards cuz
it turns out that the 5070 TI is using
the GB 203 die and while the 570 is
using the GB 205 and unfortunately in
this case a higher number does not mean
that it's better it has significantly
fewer RT cores fewer tensor cores fewer
shading units fewer tmus and fewer robs
and I think you get the point by now and
if we actually go back in time and
compare this to the 3070 family both of
those use the same GA 104 chip with the
only changes being a 4% bump in cicor a
2% bump in clock speeds and an upgrade
from gddr6 to gddr 6X
memory oh sorry lonus that's why they
perform similarly but one being a bit
more TI than the other this time around
the 5070 TI is more more like a cut down
5080 and the 5070 is more like a roided
out 5060 which would be fine if they
were priced accordingly okay but surely
there's got to be somewhere that this
card stands out oh and there is but I
don't know if you're going to like it to
nvidia's credit their AI improvements in
their Blackwell architecture do really
shine through in well our AI tests where
not only does it beat the 470 super but
but it seems to perform more like a 4070
TI super of course with that said AI
workloads really benefit from lots of
vram and the 12 gigs on this card
definitely ends up preventing it from
being legitimately useful with larger
models the updated media engine is
another bright spot though the 570 pulls
ahead of the 470 TI super IND Vinci
resolve and even gets within Striking
Distance of the 570 TI in Premier Pro
but with that said if you were thinking
oh sick well the 5070 is a productivity
Wonder kind then don't get ahead of
yourself cuz in our blender Barber Shop
test we are right back to 4070 super
performance maybe it runs super cool and
efficient though about that while the
5070 looks like its bigger Founders
Edition Brothers there's one key area
here where it loses the genetic Lottery
only one of those two fans in its blowr
design
actually blows through the fins and out
the other side this resulted in us
seeing a 73° average in F1 and a 77°
average in combuster yikes it's not
thermal throttling or anything but this
puppy is getting as hot as the 90 was
which is a little surprising given it's
using less than half of the power of the
90 it is a much smaller card making it
easier to fit in a small form factor
build or something but just make sure
you've got plenty of ventilation so it
can stay cool as cool as you'll look in
our new framework hoodie with the all
over embroidery it's expensive but it
looks cool LTT store.com really is cool
isn't it oh you're back uh all right
dunking aside the question is is this
new card for anyone and believe it or
not the answer is yes but it probably
isn't you see the target market for the
RTX 5070 is not your PC gaming
enthusiasts or your PC Building
enthusiasts it's Gamers which sound like
the same thing but hear me out see
enthusiasts are going to peep at pixels
they're going to obsess over the little
details whereas Gamers well they just
demand more pixels and higher FPS and
whether you personally like AI upscaling
or nidia's frame generation technology
which interpolates extra frames from
fewer real ones there's no doubt that
Nvidia has delivered on lots of pixels
at high frame rates and if you enable
those features the 5070 really does
match or even beat the raw numbers of
last generation's Flagship and most
Gamers unless their base frame rate is
so low that they notice the sluggish
input latency probably won't
care and I guess that's fine the problem
though is that not every game supports
these magical FPS buttons and in
unsupported titles this card is a
steaming pile and the only Silver Lining
is that I guess by sucking so hard it
probably won't get scalped much oh wait
no there is one other Silver Lining if
you can wait about 24 hours AMD is
launching a price competitor to this
thing that has 33% more vram and on
paper much better performance of course
it's AMD we're talking about here so
probably want to see just like I'll
believe this segue to our sponsor threat
Locker their zero trust World cyber
security event happened last month and I
attended to check out some of the super
cool sessions and workshops along with
some Hands-On demonstrations like where
we used a hack five rubber ducky to mess
around with some laptops and there was
also guest speakers like Reggie Fame
they also announced a few new features
insights collects data from millions of
endpoints worldwide and presents them as
actionable information saving you
countless of hours of researching and
Patch management consistently scans
devices for outdated applications and
those in need of patching plus they even
have web control which can easily build
libraries of restricted websites and add
another layer to your cyber security
cake so go learn more about the new
features to their comprehensive security
software today by clicking our Link in
the description thanks for watching guys
if you want to find out more about some
of the issues that can crop up with AI
frame gen go check out our gaming at 8K
video to uh see why it could be an issue
even if you're not an image quality snob